- Hey, everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
I just wanna thank you for taking time
out of your super busy weeks
to spend time on today's session,
and I wanna give a super special thanks
to Tim Vandenberg, who's
been gracious enough
to share his amazing story with us.
Now as you may know, Tim has been teaching
for about 25 years, including the last 18
as a sixth grade teacher
in Hesperia, California.
And while he's definitely
touched countless lives
throughout his career, in the last few
he's really discovered an
incredibly powerful way
to help help each and every
one of his students succeed
through mastery learning.
- 80% of my students
are minority students.
All of them receive
free breakfast and lunch
due to the low-income
socioeconomic disadvantage
of nearly all of my students.
And 10% of my students come to me
at grade level each year, from
fifth grade to sixth grade,
which obviously means 90% of
them are below grade level,
including about half of my class
at the lowest level, what
California might call level one,
far below grade level on their
previous year's state test,
and nearly all of my
students are reading two
or more years below grade level.
So if this sounds familiar to you,
welcome to teaching
'cause that's what most
of us struggle with here in America.
We've got lots of challenges to work with,
and some of us are blessed to
have a little less challenges
than that, but what I want you to know is
that this worked in a classroom
with real obstacles to overcome.
These were not affluent
non-minority students
who have tons of support from home.
These are struggling kids.
So, it worked for them, and
so I believe it can work
for you and your students too.
So, next slide, Jeremy.
So this is where my class came from.
If you see that little
dot on the left side,
it says Vandenberg 18/19.
My students come to me,
this is pretty typical,
60 points below passing.
That's pretty far.
That's way far, and the most recent scores
I had at the time for
California is 42 points below
in fifth grade, a passing score,
and last year they were
actually a little bit better.
I got the recent scores
after I made this chart,
so, and then the county
and district are also low.
So here's the point.
Everybody's leavin' fifth
grade, on average in California,
not everybody, but on overage, pretty low.
And you can see California, it
was two years ago is my data,
they went up.
They brought their kids 1.2
points closer to passing.
The county brought up their
students two years ago,
3.6 points closer to passing,
and the district that I teach in brought
their students up 3.6 points
more closer to passing.
So there's improvement there.
A flat line actually
means that you achieved
as a teacher a year's worth of growth
'cause they took a harder test,
the next grade level test,
and if they stayed flat,
hey, you taught them a year.
They didn't get any closer or farther,
but you succeeded keeping
them up to where they were.
But positive slopes, slopes that go up,
that's really great 'cause then
you're bringing kids closer
to their state's standard,
but you still see a huge gap there.
And my class on the far left,
way down there, far below.
So we're gonna tell the
story of what happened.
So next slide.
So in September 2016, I watched this video
from Sal Khan where he
talked about let's teach
for mastery and not for test scores.
And we're not gonna show
you the whole video,
but we are gonna show you
about a minute and a half.
Notice how Sal talks during this video,
how he talks about the insanity
of our current educational
system teaching students based
on you have nine months,
that's it, you learn what
you learn, and you move on.
Forget if you have a solid
foundation in your math,
or reading, or whatever you're teaching.
Just, no matter what, you're moving on.
Social promotion, that's just the name
of the game in most schools in America.
It's sad, but it's just the
restrictions we're given,
and so watch as Sal explains the insanity
of this education model that we don't wait
until the foundations
of learning are mastered
before building on top of that.
So go ahead, Jeremy, start
that 90-second video.
- And this will continue for months.
It'll continue for years,
all the way up to, at
some point I might be
in an algebra class or trigonometry class,
and I hit a wall.
And it's not because algebra's
fundamentally difficult,
or because of the student isn't bright.
It's because I'm seeing an equation,
and they're dealing with exponents,
and that 30% that I
didn't know is showing up.
And then I start, and
then I start to disengage.
And to appreciate how absurd that is,
imagine if we did other
things in our life that way,
say home-building.
(audience laughing)
So we bring in the contractor, say,
told we have two weeks
to build the foundation.
Do what you can.
(audience laughing)
So they do what they can.
Maybe it rains.
Maybe some of the supplies don't show up.
And two weeks later the inspector comes,
looks around, says, "Okay,
the concrete's still wet
"right over there.
"That part's not quite up to code.
"I'll give it an 80%."
Say, "Great, that's a C.
"Let's build the first floor."
(audience laughing)
Same thing.
We have two weeks.
Do what you can.
Inspector shows up in two weeks.
It's a 75%.
"Great, that's a D-plus."
Second floor, third floor,
and all of a sudden,
while you're building the third floor,
the whole structure collapses.
And if your reaction
to that is the reaction
that you typically have in education,
or that a lotta folks have in education,
you might say, "Maybe we
had a bad contractor."
Or, "Maybe we needed better inspection
"or more frequent inspection."
But what was really
broken was the process.
We were artificially constraining how long
we had to do something,
pretty much ensuring
a variable outcome,
and we took the trouble
of inspecting and identifying those gaps,
but then we built right on top of it.
So the idea of mastery learning
is to do the exact opposite.
Instead of artificially
constraining when and how long,
fixing when and how long
you work on something,
pretty much ensuring
that variable outcome,
the A, B, C, D, F, do
it the other way around.
What's variable is when
and how long the student
actually has to work on something,
and what's fixed is that they
actually master the material.
- So, as Sal was saying, why do we teach
and have our education system based
on this fixed-time model
and moving kids along
even though they're not ready
for the next grade level
or higher level of math skills?
So, and that's what he talks
about, this mastery learning.
And mastery learning means
developing each skill
to fluency and long-term retention.
And I thought, boy, I sure wish,
and I'm sure every
teacher in America wishes,
that their students came to them
with mastery learning of all of the skills
that they should have learned
in the previous grade levels.
And we all think that, "What were
"they teaching the year before?"
Well what were they teaching
the year before that?
All the way back to kindergarten,
and what were they teaching before that?
So how about instead we teach to mastery,
so next slide, Jeremy.
I had decided, after I saw that video,
that was my huge a-ha moment.
I said, "I am done dangerously building
"on the unstable
mathematical foundations!"
It's dangerous!
Why am I doing this to kids?
Next.
So for now on I'm going to teach students
with a solid number sense
and skill mastery foundation.
I'm gonna make sure my students
from now on have a solid foundation.
Even if I don't cover all the standards
that I'm suppose to teach,
I'm gonna make sure that
their life is not ruined
when they go to junior
high and high school
by actually having a
solid foundation of math,
and then maybe I can also teach them some
of their standards for the
year I'm supposed to teach.
So, Jeremy, Khan Academy
was gonna be my tool
to make that happen.
So next slide.
So in Fall 2016 I decided my
sixth grade class is going
to go back to kindergarten.
That's right.
We all know that the holes
in the foundation begin
all the way back with number sense.
Research has shown that
students' number sense,
those students who have a true grasp
and mastery of number sense are the ones
who succeed well in junior
high and high school math,
the higher level math,
algebra, calculus, and so-on.
They're the ones who really get it.
Well what if all of our
students had solid number sense?
So using Khan Academy's
menu of class options,
I assigned to my students every grade,
kindergarten, first,
second, third, fourth,
fifth, sixth, 'cause that's
what I teach is sixth,
and on the left column, the top two,
early math and arithmetic.
And those two kind of
dovetail with K through three.
Actually arithmetic goes
all the way to, even
up to a little bit of pre-algebra.
So I assigned that to all my students,
and I paced out their
learning for the whole year.
And we ended up having some
students not even finish
all of third grade, but at least
they understood the meanings of numbers
'cause they mastered K, one, two.
For the rest of their life,
for the first time in their life,
every single single student
in my class mastered
kindergarten, first, and
second grade math, truly.
So, next slide.
And so for the past three
school years doing this,
just like this, each of my
sixth grade classes have had,
it's the California state math test.
I know it's different for every state,
but that's the big high-stakes testing
that our kids in California have to take,
very rigorous, very thorough.
Their growth looks like this.
So you see my little dot on the far side.
Hey, I would be happy if they go up
at the same slope of the
county and the district.
If they just go up like that, hey,
we're performing as well as them.
That would be great.
But let's see what happened.
Jeremy, go ahead.
That is real cohort, same
kids that came to me.
That's the same kids on the left
that you see on the right.
That is real growth.
That is 95 points of growth.
That's unheard of.
I was speaking to a head data person
for a nearby school district,
and he's in charge of all their
state test data crunching,
and he told me if he saw
state test scores like that
he would assume the teacher was cheating.
But this is real.
This is kids truly
mastered their standards.
And because they had a solid
number sense foundation,
the grade level standards,
the sixth grade standards
that they were supposed to learn,
what they did cover, what we did teach,
they mastered it.
We don't just cover the
standards in my class;
we master the standards.
And I would far rather master half
of the year's standards
than just merely cover
the entire school year
of required standards
but have my kids fail in their learning.
So this is real.
So let's get into a little bit
of how to make this happen, real quick.
Oh, by the way, one of the results was
the Khan Academy recognized
my homeroom students
as one of seven National Grand
Prize LearnStorm Winners,
and that's them.
Those are real kids.
And I literally just
ran into one of the boys
in the front row, his Mom,
at Walgreens yesterday.
And she said, "Oh, my
son is doing so great.
"He's now in honors math in junior high."
And that's life change.
I would have never have guessed
that he could have achieved that,
based on his fifth
grade state test scores.
So, just amazing.
All right, next slide.
So what is this mastery
learning thing again?
I highly recommend all of you go in
and watch these videos.
It's a two-minute video of
Sal Khan himself explaining
what mastery learning
is, highly recommended.
And then also, what does this look like
in a classroom setting?
So Khan sent their video crew
to my classroom, and they
filmed for a couple days,
and you can see what it looks like,
how to make this happen
in a classroom setting
if you click on that second link.
Both of those are on YouTube,
so okay, Jeremy, next slide.
So here's how I recommend
making this happen.
First of all, be honest and
face the state test facts.
Where are your students actually at?
Quit pretending they're
higher than they are.
Do they even understand arithmetic?
Do they understand the meaning of numbers?
If you don't face that reality
and stare the truth in the face,
you will never be able
to get your students
to truly master the
standards like they need to.
Second, acknowledge
that math is cumulative.
Prerequisite skills are
exactly that, pre-required
not pre-suggested.
Unfortunately we don't have that option
they come to us whether they've mastered
the prerequisites or not.
But that's the way math is.
And so because they have to
have those prerequisite skills
before I can even teach them how to add,
subtract, multiply, divide fractions,
they gotta know what a fraction is.
They gotta know what whole numbers
and fraction parts are, and so on.
So we go all the way back to kindergarten
and use Khan Academy to remediate
and fill in those foundational gaps.
And then we teach to the Common
Core standards to mastery.
I do not cover the
standards in my classroom.
My students do not cover the standards.
We master the standards.
That is the expectation.
You don't do your homework.
You master your homework.
You don't go to recess 'cause
you finished the assignment
and failed in your learning of it.
You go to recess 'cause you
mastered the assignment.
Okay, next slide.
Fifth, believe that every child can learn.
Growth mindset, check out
the Khan Academy units
on growth mindset, amazing lessons.
Use that with your students.
Teach them to believe they can learn
because they truly can.
It happened with my students.
Most teachers would have
never guessed they could,
and this is three years in a row
that we've seen scores like that,
so it's not just a random
class this happened to.
It's consistent.
It's working.
It's repeatable.
It's real.
Sixth, teach, support.
Teach, support.
You teach, you're not
just using Khan Academy
as babysitting.
You teach, but then you
support as kids struggle.
Encourage them to come to you for help.
Watch those videos that Sal
and his crew provide online,
and use those hints.
And also have your
students help each other.
Elbow buddies, help them help each other.
Seventh, monitor progress regularly.
Intervene as soon as possible.
Don't wait until December to discover
your kids are way behind.
Intervene right away.
Eighth, set realistic long- and
short-term learning targets.
You'll see on the very last
slide is a downloadable PDF
of my class's weekly learning targets,
how to keep up pace, because I assigned
to them to do every grade
level course every week.
We don't just wait till you're done
with kindergarten before
you go to first grade.
We don't wait till you're
done with sixth grade
before you go on to the higher stuff.
You're working on every
course simultaneously.
The way the Khan learning system works,
it works best that way.
They get more done faster.
Number nine, motivate, encourage,
praise, reward, celebrate.
When a student graduates and finishes
an entire grade level to mastery,
or if you're a high school teacher,
junior high teacher, if
they finish a lower course
to mastery, we literally
have a graduation ceremony.
We give a certificate of mastery
to the students, and
Khan has some of those.
You can download those.
I'm sure Jeremy can provide them
if you email him later.
So that's what we do.
Next slide.
So this, my class last year,
that's 30 lives changed forever.
I keep hearing from parents,
and those parents, and
there's these students,
"Oh, Mr. Vandenberg, I'm doing so great
"in Junior High."
"Oh, Mr. Vandenberg, I
was stuck in the low track
"for the rest of my
life, but you intervened,
"and now I'm in honors math."
Believe it can be done.
These kids can do it.
Your kids can too.
So there you go.
I think that's it.
Last slide, Jeremy.
There's you great links.
Check out the cheat
sheet on mastery learning
that Jeremy provided.
Also, you can email me
questions, suggestions.
Reach out to me.
I'm a Khan Academy Ambassador.
I'm not paid anything to help,
but I want to help, and
so, as an Ambassador
I want to support this program.
This is changing lives all
across America and the world
if it's used to mastery.
Learn what mastery learning is,
and check out that pacing guide.
This is just a sample.
You make it fit your situation,
but download that pacing guide,
and it'll be great for you and your kids.
So, okay, Jeremy, I'll
let you kinda take over.
I'm gonna delete my video here for second.
I'll be right back.
- First of all, I wanna give
you a huge shout-out, Tim.
You totally rocked our worlds here,
even in the middle of allergy season,
so thank you so much for doing that,
all after a long day of teaching as well.
That being said, thanks for
all of the amazing questions
coming in.
We're gonna go through them in the order
they were received, so
definitely stay tuned
for lots of great answers from Tim.
Okay so, Tim, I wanna
start with this question
that was asked by
Vanessa Ridley, who said,
"Okay, I totally get
where you're coming from,
"taking your sixth graders
back to kindergarten,
"but is starting with
kindergarten realistic
"for a high school teacher?"
- Okay, that is a great question.
For high school, I
would assign, literally,
the early math.
You will discover that
your kids will struggle
with the early math skills.
They will hum along and do great,
and all of a sudden you hit a standard
in that course and realize,
"Wait, I never learned this."
And that's the very
standard that's keeping
them from understanding
the full foundation
and to build all the way up to
the high school level skills.
I would assign early math and arithmetic.
High school, they don't have time
to do K through nine, lower grade stuff.
Instead, I would assign
early math and arithmetic,
and that covers quickly all of the skills
that they need to be able to function
in your high school classes.
Or you may choose instead,
maybe if you're teaching
a higher level math class,
advanced students, or at
least at-grade-level students,
at least assign the
course before the class
that you're teaching, so they can get
those foundational skills.
If you're an algebra teacher,
assign the pre-algebra class.
If you're a pre-algebra teacher,
assign sixth grade.
But definitely, the arithmetic class,
you would be amazed how many mistakes
your students will make
on their calculus homework
because they're not solid
on their arithmetic.
- Cool, great answer, Tim,
and sort of a related question is coming
to us from Barb Wick.
She says, "Hey, if you're
gonna take students
"all the back back to kindergarten,
"how do we help them push
through that material
"when they might lose
interest or motivation,
"saying, 'Oh, I don't wanna go back
"'and do all of that'?"
- You count it as part of their grade.
And you give a reward.
You have contests.
Be the great motivational
teacher that you are.
You gotta be the coach, the teacher
that changes their life.
And you gotta sell them
on this will change
their life for math forever,
all the way through college.
They have to have these
foundational skills.
You make your judgment
call what they need.
Find those skill and assign
them in Khan Academy.
But I've gotta tell you,
having them as a sixth grade teacher,
I used to teach the high math class.
The year before I started
doing it this way,
I had my high sixth grade math class,
the advanced students,
go back to fourth grade
and do the Khan Academy fourth grade work.
They could not do it.
The gaps were so huge.
So I decided the next year,
the first year this succeeded, great,
was have, just, let's start
it back at kindergarten,
and you'll discover
kindergarten goes quick.
They're done in maybe a couple hours.
First grade they might
be done in couple days.
So don't think this takes a year to learn.
The higher grade math students,
the higher up they are, the
quicker they get through it.
And so, yeah, it just, play with it.
Make it work for you.
But I guarantee you, the issue
that we math teachers have is
their foundational
skills, like Sal describes
in that video, they're
foundational skills are still wet,
and unstable, and unsafe to build on.
And that's the reason why we're pulling
our hair out, as teachers, to get them
to learn the current-grade-level stuff
that we want them to learn.
So give them points for it.
Give them credit.
I do.
I count every single one,
as each course, as a grade,
but the lower the grade is,
the less value it's worth.
Like kindergarten is worth,
like, 1/6 of a point,
whereas sixth grade is
worth a full point, so...
- Cool.
Lots of questions about the logistics
of pulling this off.
- Right.
- Sarah Glosbach asks,
"How did you ultimately pace it out?
"Was this during core math instruction,
"tiered intervention time?
"Where did you fit this in?"
- By sixth grade they
have so much remediation,
I got permission from
my principal to allow,
I'm a self-contained classroom.
Let's just be honest.
We are teaching more than a
usual 45-minute math block,
so I had the flexibility
of allowing remediation
during class time, but
upper-grade teachers
who only teach 45 minutes to an hour,
you can assign it for homework.
They could do it, and they get excited.
They're like, "Wow, I'm
doing this stuff finally
"for the first time in my life,"
these lower-grade skills
that are never understood.
So, yes, I did have time for remediation,
but that means other things had to suffer,
but their math and their
reading are the two
most important skills in all of life.
I love history.
I'm a history major in college,
and I teach ancient history
in sixth grade.
I love that stuff.
But we had to teach less of it.
We still covered it, all the standards,
but we had to just decrease
our history time a little bit.
Maybe you high school teachers,
you principals can have
a math block just for remediation,
in addition to their
core subject math class.
A lotta classes do that.
I know the junior hight
that my students graduate
to have an extra math block
for them to learn from.
- Cool, well speaking of principals,
a very common question is the one
that was asked by Maria Quintanilla,
which is, "Did you get any pushback
"from your administration, and if so,
"how did you handle that?"
- Absolutely!
So the principal called
me in that very first year
I was doing this, 2016/2017,
the very first year,
and he said, "Hey, Mr. Vandenberg,
"I'm getting some complaints from parents
"that the kids are on their
Chromebooks a little too much.
"Are you teaching?"
And I said, "Of course.
"I'm definitely teaching,
but instead of a textbook,
"instead of their answers
being written down
"for homework at home or in class
"and not knowing if their answer is right
"or wrong until the next day when
"we go over the homework answers in class,
"instead they're instantly learning
"if their answer is
correct or not right away
"on Khan Academy."
"It gives that little happy
sound, and the kids love it.
"That's my textbook,
but I'm still teaching.
"But, yes, they are on
their Chromebooks more.
"Please, Mr. Principal."
I won't say his name
to protect the innocent
'cause he might listen to this later.
"Please allow this one year,
"and if the state test scores are not good
"I won't ever use it again,"
but if they're great,
or a lotta schools use PLCs,
professional learning communities,
where you have to have
common formative assessments
periodically, once every month or so,
couple weeks or so.
If your kids start
rocking formal assessments
and compared to their peers,
then principals start to realize,
wow, maybe this thing works.
So when my students came
back that first year,
the state test scores
blew every other classroom
out of the water in terms of growth.
Emphasize growth, okay, not,
hey, we beat the other class,
but did we go up a lot?
That's what matters as teachers.
If the scores are great,
if the growth is great,
principals get out of the way.
Literally my principal just
told me earlier this week,
"Tim, I will never ask you to change
"what you're doing in your classroom
"because of your state test scores,
"thanks to Khan Academy."
- Cool, well I know we're at the end here.
I know everyone has to either rush off
and pick up kids, make dinner, eat dinner,
but I do wanna thank everyone
for making part time
out of their busy days
to join today, and a special thank you
to you, Tim, for sharing your expertise
and making us all richer as
a result and as a community.
That being said, I know we
didn't even scratch the surface
on all the questions.
So maybe I will work with Tim,
and especially if you
could some survey feedback
right after this webinar ends
to figure out if a follow-up
session or some other resource
would be useful for you
and for your schools.
That being said, I wanna wish you
and your students tremendous
success out there,
and I wanna thank everyone for joining.
You will absolutely get a recording
of this session as well
as a copy of the slides
in your email tomorrow.
And hopefully you've been as inspired
by Tim's story as I have, and
I hope it'll carry you far,
so thanks, everyone, and
thank you so much, Tim.
- Okay, best of luck, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.